Two one boom.
So I took a four and a half hour ride down to San Diego cause my friend Brendan
was felon,
a showtime special and it was run the jewels the entire way down and back.
It was awesome.
Thank you.
Whoo.
I was,
I wish I could work out as hard as people work out.
Todd music.
Well I've lost 31 pounds,
but I'd be 90 pounds out easy now.
That was one of the things that I would say this is workout music.
Yeah,
it is.
It is an elder in our Chubbies too fat,
but,
well you were saying you lost 31 pounds.
Yeah,
maybe picked up three over the holidays.
But I'm,
I'm,
I'm on my path.
I really am.
Shouts out to Al Clayborne,
um,
who's from out here?
Who's a hell of a trainer?
If I had his discipline,
I'd already be a hundred pounds down,
but the gold is a hundred and the next 18 months you can do it.
Yeah,
I do 100%
just eat bad and got lazy.
But you know what,
man,
you could turn it.
It's one of those things where you just,
if you could stick with it for 90 days,
it will become a part of your life.
Well that's the goal.
That's the goal.
You know what I mean?
And,
and,
and I'm about it like,
cause I like meat so I still get to eat meat and I like green stuff and I don't
like salad dressing.
So I think we're going to be relatively easy for me.
Yeah.
Like olive oil and vinegar does not taste bad bro.
I don't even use that.
Like when I have a salad,
one wife make salad,
she literally will make the salad.
She may add a little goat cheese or not you,
she'll,
you know,
maybe she'll tell some chicken or some steak on there.
But if it's fruit in the salad,
I don't need any salad dressing and just throw some strawberries,
apples or stuff to salting and just give me that strive Jewson and I'm good.
If I could figure it out during that three to four times a day versus the one
meal and with my wife and then he didn't like trashing the studio.
I'll be,
that's the problems from the temptation roles.
And you see burgers and fries.
Yeah.
Fuck it.
You see a Coca Cola?
Yeah.
That,
that really is it for me.
So I had to quit sodas because the worst,
which is which is,
which brings me to cripple cola.
Yeah.
So what is critical can,
he gave me two bottles of it,
but I wanted to keep it in the fridge.
I want to enjoy it.
And it's perfect temperature,
Coca Cola,
Pepsi Cola,
RC color,
anything with Cola.
Right.
Has probably killed more Americans than anything else in the world.
So anything that's Cola,
because Coca Cola was provided tons of jobs in my hometown.
I don't want to diss them.
They might promote a concert,
am I right?
But we know that sugary drinks aren't good for you.
Right.
Yet we don't have an aversion to,
we don't criminalize sugary.
And my doctor Larry told me,
Michael,
sugar is poison,
right?
I want you to work it out of your diet.
But these kids that are members of these little punk ass street fraternity's
essentially gangs we criminalize and villainize a bunch of teenagers who simply
don't have anything to do.
They don't have jobs,
they don't have skills,
they don't have organization,
they don't have police athletic league like they used to.
They don't have people engaging them in academics or sports where they used to.
So they're just kind of,
you know,
mess off,
fuck off sometimes fuck up and violence happens,
right?
If you could take those same kids with the entrepreneurial spirit that'll sell
your water on the side of a highway and you add it to something to public
already wants anyway,
Cola,
you create something like Cripple Colin bipap and essentially what you're doing
is creating the same sugary shit that we all go buy and drink and we should.
And now we're given the structure of say a hell's angels to say,
yeah,
you could say we're a criminal organization,
but we still can sell your fucking tee shirt because we are now paid our taxes,
we're now employing people.
And we were now doing,
we're supposed to do and that's what I wanted to give the gift of my friends who
are hurt,
who are members of street fraternity's and we actually pulled it off at the
show.
These guys actually managed to bring something in microcosm to the market in
Atlanta.
It did well enough for us to keep continue doing it and I'm want to see how far
I can go and what's in it?
Sugar,
water,
artificial,
artificial arm.
What is it?
Food,
color and flavor and that's it.
I think it's six ingredients total.
Those guys.
Have you ever,
do you know what Zevia is even fuck with z?
I mean the fake sugar stuff you use,
it's no Zevia is a soft drinks that are made with Stevia.
Yeah,
but the thing is like,
you know what I found out with me with sugar to,
it's either just do it or don't.
Like for me it's easier to do things that are actually a real just sugar,
like a Mexican coke or just have,
you know,
some carbonated water with lemons in it.
I don't do well with irritation.
This Cadillac in the hand job.
I want the whole thing.
I know what you're saying,
but this stuff is good.
It's,
it's different.
It's just something,
my man who has,
who?
Justin Bieber,
he's did it.
It's just my,
I am such an addict as what the real thing.
Yeah.
So it doesn't make sense for me sometimes to tempt myself.
I'll Trump water.
I just,
I do a lot of water now,
a lot more water now.
And I do a lot of club soda with lime,
which I used to talk shit to LP about.
I a chicken white guy drinks and now it's l is ordering a fucking,
you know,
he's ordering a drink,
drink and I'm just like,
yeah,
I'll take a club soda in La.
That's good man.
If you could stick on that path.
Shouts out to my man Bariloche.
Um,
who is a friend and mentor.
A lot of times you might see a guy with me who does security bear introduce me
to Shaolin Kung Fu.
You mean basically kicking and punching and moving around.
He also introduced me to a lot of the guests that are on your show.
Um,
including,
you know,
guests that talk about intermittent fasting,
the talks about getting rid of the sugars and stuff,
and he just loves me like a big brother.
So he keeps me in tune.
But what's going on.